Philosophy is a discipline committed to helping
us to live wiser and less sorrowful lives.
Here are six ideas from its Western branch
that can inspire and console: ONE: ‘What
need is there to weep over parts of life?
The whole of it calls for tears.’ The Roman
philosopher Seneca used to comfort his friends
– and himself – with this darkly humourous
remark which gets to the heart of Stoicism,
the school of philosophy which Seneca helped
to found and which dominated the West for
two hundred years. We get weepy and furious,
says Stoicism, not simply because our plans
have failed, but because they have failed
and we strongly expected them not to. Therefore,
thought Seneca, the task of philosophy is
to disappoint us gently before life has a
chance to do so violently. The less we expect,
the less we will suffer. Through the help
of a consoling pessimism, we should strive
to turn our rage and our tears into that far
less volatile compound: sadness. Seneca was
not trying to depress us, just to spare us
the kind of hope that, when it fails, inspires
bitterness and intemperate shouting. TWO:
Peccatum Originale In the late 4th century,
as the immense Roman Empire was collapsing,
the leading philosopher of the age, St Augustine,
became deeply interested in possible explanations
for the evident tragic disorder of the human
world. One central idea he developed was what
he legendarily termed Peccatum Originale:
original sin. Augustine proposed that human
nature is inherently damaged and tainted because
– in the Garden of Eden – the mother of
all people, Eve, sinned against God by eating
an apple from the Tree of Knowledge. Her guilt
was then passed down to her descendants and
now all earthly human endeavours are bound
to fail because they are the work of a corrupt
and faulty human spirit. This odd idea might
not be literally true, of course. However,
as a metaphor for why the world is in a mess,
it has a beguiling poetic truth, as relevant
to atheists as believers. We should not – perhaps
– expect too much from the human race, Augustine
implies. We’ve been somewhat doomed from
the outset. And that can, in certain moods,
be a highly redemptive thought to keep in
mind. THREE: ‘Kings and Philosophers shit,
and so do ladies’ The blunt phrase appears
in an essay by the 16th century French philosopher,
Michel de Montaigne. Montaigne wasn’t being
mean. His point was kindly: he wanted us to
feel closer to (and less intimidated) by people
whose overt mode of life might seem painfully
impressive and very far from our own. And
he could have added: in secret these people
also feel inadequate, fear rejection and mess
up their sex-lives. We could also update his
examples to speak of CEOs, entrepreneurs,
and the over-achieving person we went to college
with. Montaigne was attempting to free us
from underconfidence and shyness, born out
of an exaggerated sense of the differences
between ourselves and mighty others. At moments
of panic, before an important speech or a
much-anticipated date, we should run Montaigne’s
phrase through our febrile, underconfident
minds and remind ourselves that no one, however
outwardly poised, is more than a few hours
away from a poignantly modest and vulnerable
moment. FOUR: ‘All our unhappiness comes
from our inability to sit alone in our room’
This assertion, by the 17th century French
philosopher Pascal, is obviously not literally
true. But like all good philosophical aphorisms,
it pointedly exaggerates an important idea
in order to bring home a general insight.
We are tempted to leave ‘our room’ and
crave excitements that too often turn out
badly; we meddle in the lives of others but
fail to help them; we seek fame and end up
being misunderstood by large numbers of people
we don’t know. ‘Sitting alone’ doesn’t
mean literally being on the bed but rather,
staying undistracted with ourselves: appreciating
small pleasures; examining the contents of
our own minds, allowing the quieter (but important)
parts of our psyche to emerge; thinking before
we act. It’s a poignant phrase because the
louder voices in our culture are constantly
speaking in the opposite direction; are always
goading us to get out more, to grow more agitated,
to seek more drama and to spend less time
in thoughtful reveries, gazing out of the
window at the clouds passing high above. We
should, with Pascal’s encouragement, learn
to become better friends to ourselves. FIVE:
Sub specie aeternitatis It means, translated
from the Latin, ‘under the aspect of eternity’
– a memorable phrase from the Ethics, published
in 1677 by the Dutch philosopher Baruch Spinoza.
For Spinoza, the task of philosophy is to
teach us to look at things, especially our
own suffering and disappointment, ‘under
the aspect of eternity,’ that is, as though
we were gazing down at the earth from very
far away or from a different star (Spinoza’s
outlook was much indebted to Galileo). From
this lofty perspective, the incidents that
trouble us no longer have to seem so shocking
or so large. What is a divorce or a sacking
when contemplated from the lunar surface?
What is a rejection in love judged against
the earth’s 4.5 billion year history? Our
nature means that we’ll always be pulled
to exaggerate the here and now, but our reasoned
intelligence gives us access to a unique alternative
perspective, in which we participate in what
Spinoza called ‘eternal totality’, and
can cease railing against the status quo,
submitting to the flow of events with clear-eyed
serenity instead. SIX: Aus so krummem Holze,
als woraus der Mensch gemacht ist, kann nichts
ganz Gerades gezimmert werden. It’s a slightly
daunting and long German phrase but a hugely
arresting and redemptive one, central to the
spirit of Western philosophy: ‘Out of the
crooked timber of humanity, no straight thing
was ever made.’ So wrote the German eighteenth
century philosopher Immanuel Kant, who urged
us to recognise that nothing that human beings
do can ever be less than slightly wonky, because
we are creatures as much of passion and erroneous
instinct as of reason and noble intelligence.
The wise accept this dark reality head on
and so do not expect perfection. When designing
governments, they do not presume that rationality
will triumph; they do everything to assume
that error and folly will try to have their
way – and create structures to contain them.
When they marry, with comparable realism,
they never expect that one person can be everything
to them and then harangue a partner when they
turn out not to be. An acceptance of our crooked
nature isn’t dispiriting, it’s the birth
of generosity and dark good humour. Not least,
added Kant, crooked beams can make for beautiful
floors, in the hands of a talented carpenter.
If you want to learn more about the thinkers from our videos,
check out our Great Thinkers Book. Available world wide and now as an e-book.